we strolling players would still be
performing for hands full of people were
there no cameras to record our actions
early screen actors worked an outdoor
sunshine and the people who recorded
them learn to control light to darken it
diffuse it bounce it and bend it they
turned their science into the art we now
acknowledge a cinematography while still
working to perfect black and white
movies impatient men were experimenting
with color in 1903 some scenes in the
Great Train Robbery were painstakingly
colored by hand a process called
kinemacolor captured the ample charms of
the legendary Lillian Russell in 1912
Technicolor was a sensational all-color
process that reached its glory with Gone
with the Wind
today's faster film smaller cameras and
sharper lenses allow modern artists to
bring even more realistic emotional
portraits to our screen the five
cinematographers nominated by their
peers are Allen da vo for Avalon Dean
Semler for Dances with Wolves
Vittorio Storaro for Dick Tracy Gordon
Willis for Godfather Part three Philippe
Brusilov for Henry and June
congratulations Anthony and the Oscar
goes to Dean Semler Dances with Wolves
it's a bit like facing 3,000 Buffalo
I think dancers would have been a
fabulous fine movie even if it had been
shot on super 8 and Kevin and Jim all I
can say is thanks thanks for having me
aboard and thanks for not shooting it in
super 8 I had a I had a fabulous crew
that were very supportive and I love
them all and thank them all my wife
Annie the blonde bombshell from Down
Under thanks but order Ingrid hi thanks
for your love your patience I'm a very
proud little Ozzie up here tonight to
accept this and I thank you all I think
the Academy and I think America thinks